i'm going to talk about closure
core async i'll try to i really want to
talk about the motivation behind it and
how you should think about it but i will
talk enough about the details so you get
a sense of what the api is like but it's
not fundamentally about how to use it or
the code so what problems are we trying
to solve
the first problem we're trying to solve
is the fact that function chains make
poor machines and uh if you've heard me
speak before about
how objects are uh were
are like little machines and they're not
very good for doing logic
functions like little use you know units
of logic that are bad for making
machines
and it ends up that because we're moving
to this world where
people are trying to be more reactive we
have a ton of callback apis on our hands
and we tend to connect to them
with chains of function calls and we're
in a situation where we actually need
a program that's more like a machine
we're trying to use tools that are for
functional programming to do that and
it's a bad
fit so
how do we fix this so the the idea
behind uh
behind this and it's something that i've
said often is that uh
good programs should be made out of uh
processes and cues
you know at a higher level you want to
move to cues and you want to move to
cues
in particular as soon as you're involved
in any kind of conveyance within your
application because at that point
it's no longer nested logic you're
trying to
move something from one place to another
maybe from some input
through processes in your system that
perform calculations or transformations
and eventually out somewhere else that's
a one-way
street so we want conveyance to become
first class
we want to organize our programs this
way and we could always do this right if
we're on the jvm that it already has
cues often people have said you know why
is enclosure wrapped queues and it's
because
you know there's already queues and
they're perfectly fine and enzymes are
not perfectly fine and we're going to
make them a little bit better with this
potentially but they're there
and they work but they do have some some
problems
one is that the only way you can
coordinate with a cue
with the java util concurrent queue in
other words to
wait for data to be present is to take
an actual thread a real thread
and and block on the queue
and uh that has a cost we're gonna talk
about in a second
um also if we try to look at the whole
scope of
platforms that closure addresses uh
which also include javascript through
closurescript
there are no real threads there and
there are no cues there
of any real sort so using cues directly
looking for cues
from the host is not necessarily
something we can always do
even when we can do it there are
overheads associated with cues
and people make a lot of this and in
particular on jvm there's a definite
overhead
per thread i'm sorry not with queues
associated with threads
which is the stack size you know every
thread has a pretty big stack and if you
tried to have
hundreds or tens or hundreds of
thousands of threads uh you'd consume a
huge amount of memory
there's also wake up time and other you
know overheads associated with threads
people often talk about that as if it
was a scalability thing scalability is
not about what happens inside one
machine it's about
being able to add machines or add
resources to make to make things scale
but it is an efficiency problem right
are we making the best use of the
machine
by using a thread per connection
oftentimes we're not
so we'd like an alternative to that
so the
the api du jour is events and callbacks
right this is all back
all the ick from a long time ago from ui
development is now like
the way to do everything we have
listenable futures and promises and
callback handlers and
async apis for every kind of rpc
and and invariably they expose
themselves as these um
you know listenable future or some sort
of a callback and what we end up doing
is we put
some logic in into each of these
callbacks that says on a button click or
on a
message coming over the pipe or on or
whatever do this stuff and so the stuff
is a little piece of logic that we hook
up there
and there are lots of these sources of
events and we end up with lots of pieces
of logic
and we end up with this giant web of
these direct
call relationships a lot like the kinds
of webs we create in object oriented
programs
and similarly they're very difficult to
reason about or do control flow and
everybody understands
this phrase callback hell we're going to
really look more carefully at what that
means and what it
uh what it's about but fundamentally i
think it's about having to break your
logic up into little pieces so that
those pieces of logic can live inside
handlers
when those pieces are part of a design
or a way of thinking about a state
machine
or a way to approach the problem that
was all of a piece
and the fact that you divided it up has
nothing to do with the way you want to
think about the problem
and everything to do with the artifact
of this mechanism
for addressing it and it makes
everything difficult
it's difficult to see inside these
things to see which uh
callbacks call which handlers to monitor
them um
you know on what thread are the
callbacks going to be run et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and there have been very you know
various uh
approaches to try to mitigate some of
this with observables and rx and things
like that but they only handle a very
narrow set of cases mostly you know
filtering or making a streamlike kind of
approach to composable transformations
on a single event chain but if if you
really are trying to make a state
machine that has
multiple sources and sinks of events
uh you can't just get it out of
something like a filter and map
composition
primitives so what does that look like
the problem looks like this essentially
i mean i don't care if in and out
are cues or or
external api calls or sockets or button
clicks in a browser or whatever it's
just all sort of generically
stuff comes from somewhere else that's
input it's outside of your program and
somehow it's going to show up and say
woo
pay attention to me right you have some
logic associated with that which you're
going to put in a handler
for that and eventually that logic is
going to have to produce something and
and move it along so at the top part
here
can i wiggle my mouse over this oh no
you don't see that
okay maybe i can point
you don't see that either okay up
up above uh the in to the logic and out
those are all function calls right the
the input thing is on something
you know call this function and inside
that function you eventually call you
know
print or send it out or update the dom
or something like that
and this this box is not a whole box
because
the way you thought about this job may
have been a state machine maybe you're
trying to implement you know some
algorithm you're trying to implement uh
some sort of a state machine and in fact
it involves multiple inputs and multiple
outputs but because you have to break it
up into these
pieces you end up with these small
fragmented things
and the problem is if you really did
have a state machine model
you had some logic appear that may or
may not need to do something in
particular depending on something that
happened in the logic down below
and how are you going to coordinate
those two things because they're both
getting separate event streams and
they're both
running on each event and the way you do
that invariably is
having to introduce some shared state
and
we all know the kind of party that leads
to
and so objects don't fix this right i've
just just put this in a blue
oval that's about that's all that they
do
there's nothing nothing fundamental
about
what we just talked about is change by
putting in an object
okay objects are like marionettes right
where you know anybody can pull any
string at any time
you know and you're not going to get an
episode of the thunderbirds out of that
um so so there are interesting things
out there you know this happens all the
time
what's the problem the problem is we had
to take what would have been a single
thread of control we had to break up
into pieces so that we could run it on
callback handlers
and you know some people have done work
in this area already
c-sharp and f-sharp have async
primitives not necessarily oriented
around callbacks but they do something
they are solving the problem of the what
i would call reversion of control
right which is that you want to call
some asynchronous operation you want to
continue
to use your thread or give your thread
back to a pool
and eventually uh when whenever you were
waiting for
whatever you were waiting for comes back
somehow
resume control and so the way c sharp
style async works is that it takes
a code that looks linear but that calls
asynchronous
rpcs for instance and we'll
turn the code in place into a state
machine and actually register that state
machine on the callback handler so your
code looks
ordinary and linear and this inversion
of control is happening
under the hood so it's an interesting
idea
to uh to copy this i don't know who who
saw philip's
uh scala async talk earlier good
so uh so it's not a bad idea to uh to
think about copying this and
scala did that and i saw phillips talk
in the spring i guess
and i was like that's not a bad idea
we could just copy that enclosure and it
would look like something like this and
this is not what we ended up doing
but it shows you the idea right so up
top you have traditional
blocking code right you there's some
future the future is blocking when you
de-ref it
you're waiting you're wasting you're
tying up the thread
and you're wasting resources in the
second place uh
you use something like call back so now
you have a
a listenable future and you'd say on
completion of the future you know do
this job
and it looks kind of straightforward
here but if you were in the middle of a
loop
uh or something else or you had multiple
things you wanted to wait on
this would get really nasty trying to
fabricate what the callback handler
would be
and have a capture the context of a of a
linear looking program
segment would be very difficult so
what c-sharp style async does is it says
we'll just put that
code in some sort of a special construct
we'll call async
and then instead of registering a
handler with a callback or actually
blocking on it
you'll make a call to await which
semantically is blocking it's like the
first it's like the first code here
but some magic and in the case of c
sharp as some compiler magic
is going to go and look at this block of
code and say okay
i see that you're trying to do an
asynchronous thing let me analyze this
block of code let me turn it into a
state machine
that actually can be called back let me
enric
register that state machine as the
callback handler
for that future and relinquish the
thread
so the thread is no longer running and
what happens is the code that you want
to have
be the continuation if you will of of
that future
is stored away in an in a in a in a blob
of a state machine
that will eventually be called upon to
run
on us on a thread from a thread pool
and that allows you to share and it's a
it's really a great
approach to this it makes for linear
code and
allows you to use the machine
efficiently because you can share this
thread pool you can have lots of these
pending
you know future actions but notice in
particular this is
really our pc and that's sort of the
problem
you know i walked away from the talk
saying that would be a cool thing to
copy and then like after a weekend i was
like
uh yeah because the promises and futures
it's not actually the first problem i
talked about right the first problem i
talked about was
true asynchrony right somebody clicks on
a button
or something comes over a socket your
code didn't initiate that
the same way the code we saw on the
previous slide did that's code that says
go and do this and then when it's done
you know come back and i want to
relinquish the thread in the meantime
these things are actually happening
asynchronous
so promises and futures are sort of uh
lightweight constructs
you know they're one-night stands right
they're just handoffs or
call and return scenarios they can't
really model
you know enduring connections and so
they're not actually help for
for this so it's sugar i mean it's it's
good sugar
um but i i felt like we should put it on
a better cake
so what do we do again i think that
people who are writing production server
programs
already use queues and this is the way
most large
server things are decomposed they aren't
a giant you know
web of direct calls there's cues
invariably inside
inside everything and they have a lot of
great properties right they decouple
producers and consumers
right who's putting the things on one
end of this who cares who's on the other
end
nobody cares right they don't know about
each other it's somewhere down there
someone's going to take this thing
right they're first class you know
there's that queue there's that conveyor
belt right there you can go you can kick
it touch it you can talk about it name
it
um bump into it you know it's it's out
it's outside
um they're enduring right the person
who's on this end putting boxes on
takes a break and somebody else comes up
and the person on the other end
is sick today and somebody else comes
out with this conveyor belt is still
there
it's there in spite of people coming and
going
potentially because it's first class and
external and a thing
it's it's an easier place to hook on
some monitoring and
supports multiple readers and writers
so of course there's nothing new to
invent it's just a matter of finding
stuff so um the thing to be found in
this case is csp
which goes back to tony horde's work in
the in the 70s
uh sort of like the parallel uh track as
actors and their csp you know so
pick pick your fight so we're gonna
we're gonna
take this side with uh with core async
and
bet on csp as many others have and it
has some very interesting
characteristics
maybe not always in the not all in the
first paper but over
time csp has come to represent
first-class channels
as being the only way that independent
processes interact with one another
there's no shared state except for these
channels
the semantics are blocking by default
which means that you can also use them
for coordination
uh which is quite interesting so it's
not just a primitive for conveyance
it can be a primitive that allows you to
say you know um stay here until
somebody's ready
for me or vice versa
they can also be buffered and then
therefore allow for
for some asynchrony between the
producers and consumers and uh
you know there's a long set of history
behind this ocam and
uh implementations for java and of
course the most recent
uh rendition that sort of makes this
first class and a central point of
language is
the go language um so we're we owe
everything about what you're going to
see to all of this prior work
but there are lots of cool attributes to
this right the multi-reader multi-rider
part is
important you can pass endpoints around
those first class things
the other cool thing about um csp and
channels is that they support
choice uh via a
a mechanism called either select or alt
depending on what language or what paper
you're reading
and the the purpose there is that you
can wait on one or more of a set of
i o operations on channels those
includes both rights reads
and timeouts in addition uh through time
and in the academic literature and work
there is
uh formalisms and proofs and things like
that that can be used to help you reason
formally about uh systems built in this
style
there's nothing in that area yet done
for uh
for core async so there are already
people that have done this there's a
very nice implementation of csp for java
called java csp people have tried stuff
in scala
but both of these implementations are
tied to real threads they basically use
real threads as processes
one to one and we want to do something
else for closure
in particular we want to try to create
an implementation of this uh
this approach that works both for
closure and
closure script and that supports both
the problem of
i want to use real threads and real
blocking which still has utility
if you do not have an arbitrary number
of connections you need to support if
you have a small server with a finite
number of processes
it can be more efficient and have higher
throughput to use genuine threads and
real blocking
than to force everything to go through
the mechanism of
a thread pool uh but if you are trying
to target um
arbitrary uh connection counts or
work on a platform that doesn't have
threads at all which would be
uh the javascript engine you need
something else and so the idea here if
there's any
new idea in core async it's just to
implement this technology
on platforms that weren't designed for
it like if you look at go
it has a runtime engine that's oriented
around this
and to get the more efficient uh
use of threads and thread pools by
leveraging
the kind of immersion of control
technology that was used in c-sharp
async
right because that's what you need to
take code that should
logically be blocking and instead turn
it into data
and eventually consume a thread from a
thread pool
so that's the that's the idea so
if we can do this this is really great
right because we can we can deal with
traditional threaded apps with
low thread counts we can approach you
know designs for high connection count
servers that are efficient
you can deal with evented server apis
like those provided by node invert
and you know we can finally try to make
some
sanity in browser development
not targeted currently by core async has
anything to do with
extending this over the network
all right so corey sync itself what is
it it's a library um
it's it's about fundamentally
coordinating between
processes using channels but the
processes you can think of as
independent threads of activity
they may be real threads or they may be
these inversion of control threads where
you write code
that looks like it's doing x do y do z
in a row and blocking in the middle and
that process is turned into data
whenever the blocking occurs and the
real thread is relinquished so we'll
call those inversion of control threads
and we'll threads like this
but logically the threads and the
semantics are the same
we want the semantics of threads and the
semantics of blocking
in all cases because it allows us to
write linear code
and then we'll connect these things with
these q-like channels
and target both platforms so the the
first thing you need to be able to do is
create a thread or create a process
and there's two ways to do it uh there's
the thread call
which is a lot like the future call
except this uh you know could tap into
different thread pools
and is clear about what you're doing
when you say thread you get an actual
real thread
and when you use the apis within this
thread you get real blocking
so it's not quite as you can't create as
many of these
arbitrarily as you could with the next
ones
but when you want real threads and you
know what you're doing
you can get high throughput with
something like this and then we have go
and go is the same kind of thing it
creates a logical thread
it runs the block inside of it in this
mode whereby if you issue any blocking
calls
this mechanism will come into play
create an inversion of control state
machine out of your code
and and register it on the handler for
the uh
asynchronous callback so we're going to
talk about that as a thread
where blocking we're going to call
parking which essentially
relinquishes the thread and takes the
code and parks it
somewhere for its resumption later
all right so channels themselves what
are they they're like queues right a cue
you put something on one end you take
stuff off the other end that's it
that's what they're about put stuff in
one end take stuff out the other end
you can have multiple writers you can
have multiple readers fundamentally
channels are blocking like with that if
you don't touch them and do anything
else
they're blocking that means that if
somebody comes in to
read and no one's written anything it
waits if somebody comes in to write
and no one's waiting to read the writer
waits they block on both sides
they can be um i mean by default they're
unbuffered we also support some fixed
buffering
so i'll talk about that in a second so
the api is pretty straightforward you
create channel with chan
chan with no arguments creates an
unbuffered channel which is essentially
synchronous
rendezvous you can say chan with n which
gives you a
buffer of that size or chan with a
buffer and there's a couple of api calls
that allow you to create buffers
and we can put with uh put that's how we
we read that right arrow bang
right angle bang and that's the parking
variant
right that's the one that will park the
thread that must be used within a go
block
the other variant is the double bang and
you can read those as blocking
put blocking and all those flavors and
this will go throughout the api if
there's a double bang
it's a blocking call you read it as blob
blocking so put blocking
and none of those are available on
closurescript on javascript because
there are no threads to block
similarly this take and take blocking
and close
what's really useful about this if
you're using it on the jvm is that you
can mix and match these
so you can have a bunch of go threads
and you can have actual real threads
you can make blocking calls and parking
calls on the same channels on different
ends of the same channels it all
fully interoperates which can be
extremely useful
so the buffers themselves again normally
were unbuffered
or by default were unbuffered and that
acts as a rendezvous like i said readers
wait for writers and vice versa
if you supply a fixed buffer you use n
of some value
then uh rights will succeed right away
until the buffer is full and then the
rights will block
uh you know block like this and then
there are two flavors of buffers that
will never block a writer because
they've incorporated a policy about what
to do when they're full
and one is a sliding buffer which
effectively
walks across and drops the newest stuff
and a dropping buffer which is if you
come to it with new stuff and it's full
already it just drops whatever you send
and they will never block um the
provider
what we will not we do not provide and
will not provide
are unbounded buffers this is just a
recipe for a broken program
it's just like i don't feel like seeing
this bug till later so i'll make an
unbounded
buffer i'm not going to help you do that
we've already
probably rejected the patch request a
couple of times and we'll keep doing it
i mean just hopefully people will get
tired of submitting it
just don't do it i mean what's beautiful
about this is that you can establish a
policy
eventually we'll have a recipe for
providing other policies
um with more sophistication uh but you
know
make a decision you need to make a
decision here you can't just have
stuff piling up all around in memory and
not be thinking about it
so it's it's a value proposition of of
csp and of of core async that you're
thinking about these things and making
choices
so the other cool thing extremely cool
thing about
csp and about channels is the fact that
they offer choice
so it's quite frequent that you want to
make
you want to put a state machine in
particular in a state where it's waiting
for one or more
possible activities or operations to
succeed
um and that can be really difficult
thing to do that's something for
instance that
none of the java q primitives support at
all windows has some nice
primitives for weight on multiple things
but java does not obviously sockets do
have select and whatever so alt
and the two flavors of alt alts are
are functions that take a set of
operations
and operation is one of two things if
it's just a channel it means
try to read something from this channel
if it's a vector with a channel and a
value it means try to put this on a
channel
and alts will return
[Music]
whenever one of those things becomes
ready to complete
and by default it will be random there's
also a priority option that will let you
say try them in this order what's really
important about the choice is that
one and only one operation will complete
so you're going to ask for
you know let me know when any one of
these things has happened but only one
of them will happen it will be as if
all the other pending requests you made
were cancelled
and you just got the one thing and you
get a return value which indicates
in the case of take it's just the value
in the uh
in the case of take where you had
multiple channels it's going to tell you
which channel actually succeeded and
what the value was
in the cases of put it's just going to
be like okay that worked that channel
put worked and then there's a macro
that combines this function with uh with
cond
you know with the with the logical
branching so basically you say
alt bang which is not a function now
this is a macro
you supply one or more sets of
operations you want to attempt
right the whole set of operations is
going to be tried sort of in parallel
and the first thing that's available to
complete will be
the result of the condition so we have
uh
i think i have arrows here let's see so
the operations themselves the first two
are
reads try to read from c or t or try to
read from
x or try to put this vowel to out
and or if none of them are ready right
now just return 42.
then we have uh expressions right which
would be the result if c
or t returns a value then we want to
grab that value and call it val and grab
the channel that actually succeeded
because it could be
c or t and call that ch and then we'll
call foo with those two things so we
have a binding
and then some expressions so this is a
you know it's a macro that is an
expression
it's not got all the you know [ __ ] of go
with uh statements
and it will return one of the values so
you're going to try multiple operations
um and you can have a default if none of
them are ready otherwise you'll block
waiting for one of them to succeed
you can get the value that you know you
desire
as a result of that particular operation
uh succeeding
so it's like alts plus cond
so how do you do timeouts because a lot
of times what happens is you're setting
off all these blocking things but you
don't want to wait forever
what's really cool about go is that they
decided to make timeouts
channels themselves and that's a really
good idea
so well worth copying so you just create
a timeout by calling timeout with the
number of milliseconds
you get a channel that closes after that
number of milliseconds
so you can put that into an alts um and
what will happen is either you're going
to get something from the thing
that's not a timeout or the timeout will
close and that will cause your alts
to have a completed operation which is
the closing of the of the timer channel
but the cool thing about it is that
timeout now is a real thing
as opposed to how many people like
putting timeouts in api calls
yeah that stinks right especially if you
tried to coordinate multiple things or
you know you're just not sure how long
to wait or you're trying to do stuff in
a loop where you have to keep
trying things but you're trying to have
an overall counter go down so you have
to keep recalculating that timeout
smaller smaller smaller smaller now you
can just create a timeout once and say
i'm going to try all this stuff
in a loop for three seconds you create a
three second timeout you keep passing
that same thing
into every api call the same one because
it's either going to
complete or not and you just reuse it so
you can share them
which is very powerful so obviously if
you know go this is very similar
um it's it's like go but the things that
are different are
all of the operations everything i've
shown you they're all expressions it's
for a functional programming language
there's no statements that you don't
need to have state to start
interoperating with channels
because channels are a state mechanism
already
it's a library it's not a language
feature it uses macros
to do what it does and the macros are
quite interesting and we'll have to have
other talks about those
but the go macro is the thing that
inverts control and sets up the state
machines for you
the other thing that's interesting is
that alts is a function you can map it
it's variatic
it supports a runtime variable number of
operations you can't do that with any
construct and go because they're all
statements and we support priority
so um so how do we integrate this into
our world right because we're not going
to get everybody to change their apis to
use channels
right they already use callbacks are you
know are we doomed
and the answer is no right the the trick
is
as soon as you're in the handler and
something comes in the handler
just put it in a channel and that's it
you should be done don't put
anything more there so we actually have
because the operators that put like the
right angle
um yeah the right angle bang put it can
only be used inside go and you're not in
a go block in this
event handler right you just like on
mouse click that wasn't in a go block
what do you do we have two calls put and
take which can be used from
outside of go blocks that are
asynchronous and they'll just encue the
request
return right away it's sort of an entry
point from the edges of your system into
the channel based system
so you're talking about a process that
wasn't part you know wasn't really a csp
process
has got some input you use put to
introduce it into this system and so
there's a similar
take which you know reverts control is a
way to get out
for instance in javascript and get a
callback back
so speaking of javascript so what do we
do there um
yeah this is the browser it's just all
callbacks there's 100 callbacks
and uh again this is totally fine
everything i'm showing you especially
everything about the go blocks not the
ones
that not the thread ones it all works in
the browser all works in closure script
if you read
david nolan's post about this he's doing
you know fantastic things
that are exactly what this was designed
to do
right you just revert control
immediately in your handler right don't
put
any logic in your handlers just take the
event
turn it into data put it on a channel
and
be done with it and that will let you
put your world right side
right side up so it's just a way to
restore
the separation of concerns right instead
of fragmenting your logic
and building all these little pieces
everywhere you keep your logic together
you use these bridges from channels to
get stuff to route through
so the model essentially looks like this
right in contrast to the first one that
you're going to just take inputs
and put them on channels you're going to
have your logic all together
you can consume from multiple channels
it can put on multiple channels it can
coordinate with other logic and other
instances of the logic because it's it's
many to many um but it's it's all
together and it puts it on channels and
eventually those
reach reach the out outside world um
and uh so i the
the the super critical thing is this
part of the talk
okay because we have two solutions here
that uh on the tin right they're the
same
these let you efficiently do
asynchronous programming
it's like great it's feature awesome
dude let's go do it
right but they're really really
different
the characteristics are completely
different so
it's a battle direct versus indirect
right so how many differences can you
see between these things except for some
colors
it looks like good you know it looks
more of a hassle right i have five
things down here i had
four things up there always a bad
measure so
latency logic in the direct system it's
split up into tiny pieces and spread out
through callback handlers
in an indirect system it's coherent
right it's all together it's linear
right what happens on your callback it
directly calls your logic which
structure calls the output it's all this
big chain of fire fire fire
unless you manually introduce some more
asynchrony
right it's synchronous right channels
can be synchronous or not right we can
set them up with with no buffering and
actually cause workflow
and back pressure waiting or we can add
buffering and get some more asynchronous
asynchrony there we still have uh
have choices in the logic itself right
what's the arity of the callback to the
callee that's built in it's like you
gave them a piece of code to call you
they call that code it's the one to one
button click calls the thing
on socket calls or whatever right it's
end to end
here right with asynchrony how many
people can feed this channel as many as
you want how many people can consume it
as many as you want so you can share the
work you can have multiple sources
you can do routing you can create these
relationships dynamically you can pass
the channel to talk to dynamically this
other stuff has got code
i made code and the code has got like
what to call
up above right so that's all implicit
where am i going
from here it's like inside this piece of
code
where am i going from here i don't know
i mean there's going to be some code
that wires the stuff together which i'm
going to be able to see and think about
and cooperate with and possibly manage
dynamically
something you can't possibly do in the
other in the other scenario
where is the shared state well sort of
an internal implementation detail of you
know whatever you had to do to try to
make your state machine cross
multiple callback handlers which is
usually just a
real incredible mess right where is it
here it's external
right it's not like there's no state
right there is state
they're of course their state it's a big
machine right it moves stuff from there
out the other side right but in the top
we're making function calls but how do
we know we're using function calls wrong
up top
right we functions calling functions
calling functions there's nothing wrong
right
that's a call chain we do that all the
time in functional programming but what
else do we also do
we pay attention to the return values
right
function calling function calling
function we're getting the return using
it getting the return using again in
return using it
is fine that's function composition to
have a
stack of functions serve an algorithmic
purpose that's not what we're doing up
top right we're shoveling stuff across
functions
ignoring the return values and trying to
spew stuff out into the real world at
the other end
so having the having the state be
external is
totally fine it's now clear that there
is state and i think this is very very
interesting
right these states are different right
the shared state that you have between
two pieces of logic in order for them to
communicate with each other is going to
be place
state it's going to be i put something
in there you know i scrolled away some
acorns so that either when i come back
or this other handler comes in they know
that i'm in the middle of doing this and
they should not do that
or you know we've got six of these and
we need four more before we can proceed
um there's going to be the shared state
which is a set of places
that you're using to uh to update things
but
i think what's really cool about first
class channels
is that they expose a subset of state
and it's a very interesting and
far safer one which i'll call flow state
right which is just about
all you can do with this kind of state
is put stuff in it and then you really
don't know anything more about it or you
can take stuff out of it and you really
don't know how it got there
and uh the analogy i'd make is you know
let's say you work at a factory right
you get into the factory and you have
your jacket
right you're going to do something with
your jacket would you rather
hang it on a coat hook or put it on a
conveyor belt
that's moving or dump it down a laundry
chute
or put it in the back of the ups truck
that's about to leave
well it's quite there's a difference
right those are all places to put your
jacket right
but what what is it about the coat hook
right you expect to go back there
at the end of the day and see your
jacket still there
of course if there's only a few coat
hooks and there's a lot of jackets
you have this contention problem because
it's a place but you would never put
your jacket on any of those other kinds
of
places states because you know they're
going
their flow they're going to go away it's
going to go on a conveyor belt it's
going to
you know it's going to go somewhere else
it's going to go down that shoot you
can't recover it the
ups truck is going to drive away and
that's good
because you can't possibly have your
life depend on going back
and seeing the same thing there again so
it's not really like
state the way shared state and place
oriented state is
flow state is much simpler it's much
easier to read
reason about and much safer
because you don't do not have this
expectation of coming back
right and then in any case if if you're
running any of these things in
in an environment in which that not only
is there you know
cooperative concurrency but there's
actual real simultaneous concurrency
then any kind of state whether it's a
channel or or the shared state there is
going to have to have some coordination
right so we don't all
step on each other but in the first case
whose
problem is it it's your problem right
that coordination getting that thread
safe is your problem
in this problem in the in the
in the bottom uh case it's my problem
right
it's the it's the core async library
problem and once we get it correct
i think we've already gotten it correct
but it's correct for everybody
right it's share its correctness is
shared by everyone
so you know which do you want uh also
the logic right when do you when do you
decide to handle an event that comes
through a callback handler
you don't decide right you're like
you're just passive you you get called
whenever you get called right
when do you have it when you have uh
channels and and
uh alt whenever you choose right if you
don't want to go read that channel right
now
don't do it right if you think it's more
important to read this other channel or
to write to these channels or to wait
for 10 minutes or to go ask somebody
you're not a passive
a passive recipient of of control being
driven from an external event
unless you've chosen to do that right so
i think the problem i labeled first is
the one i want to call out now right
this first thing is using code as a
queue
right call to call to call to call
when we should always be using data
again it's one of these things we never
make this mistake
when we go over wires we never make this
mistake
when we go over wires we don't the
reason is because we can't
wires don't let us make function calls
right we always have to turn it into
data
put it in a buffer and cue it shovel it
over
dequeue it do whatever maybe we'll map
it again to a function call and we'll
recreate our pc but there's no rpc wires
don't do rpc they're not code
they don't have entry points you can't
invoke them
so we never do this then but it's a good
example of another thing that when we
bring it inside
um we make this mistake and when we're
shoveling stuff around
inside our programs it's not different
than when we're shoveling around between
boxes it's not different shouldn't be
shouldn't be a different way to think
about it so
um there's a sense in which this the
direct callback approaches
is intimacy right it's it's making
pieces aware of the other pieces right
the call
callback event knows who to call the
caller knows where it goes next
and it's all code and uh and there's a
sense in which
using channels and this indirection is
ignorance
and we all know that ignorance is bliss
and it ends up that in systems it's also
it's also bliss
and at least in systems
intimacy is pain this is where the pain
comes from this
is why this is why it's painful
so uh here's a little bit of code just
so that i don't just show ideas on the
screen and get complained about
so code this is a great example from rob
pike's
rob pike's example's for go and it's
just nice because it shows everything
i'm not showing the supportive code the
basic idea here is that you've got a job
you're trying to do the search you need
to come up with a web and image and a
video
result for it you have a couple of
possible sources of these answers
they may reply at different speeds you
want to bound the amount of time that
you're going to take
to do this entire job to 80 milliseconds
you want to try to get everybody to do
the job
and take the first results you get and
get out so
the function fastest takes a query and
and uh you know two sources
right two uri endpoints that it can call
it's going to create a channel it's
gonna set off
go processes to go and attempt to
do that rpc with each of those web
servers and get an answer
and and each of those callbacks are
going to go and take the answer they get
and put it on that channel
and then fastest is going to return the
channel so essentially you can read this
as
set off set off two processes racing to
put an answer on a channel
and return the channel and you do that
similarly for the images and similarly
for the video so we end up with three
channel results right and we're going to
set off asynchronous processes that are
going to go and say
read from that channel then put it on
the shared channel
so and it's going to do one right so
that read and then put back that's the
rpc kind of thing and there's no you can
build
right that c-sharp style async rpc stuff
out of
channel reading channel right like this
and it's a common idiom right
so it's going to read each one and put
it on there and then we have a loop
and the cool thing is that this loop it
doesn't know where this stuff comes from
it's just been told
there are going to be three answers on
this channel uh
don't spend more than 80 milliseconds
trying to read them
and that's what it does it goes through
it it makes an alt call and it says
try to read from the channel or time out
take the value and just add it to the
vector so this vector is going to return
up to possibly three results or
nils if no results are available but
it's going to be done in 80 milliseconds
no matter what
given that spec for this is the job you
want to do
that would be really hard to write
without stuff like this
so what do you get from using this kind
of technology you get a separation of
concerns you get it back
right because you've lost it you get
coherent and linear logic
right and you move away from mutation
you know if you have a state machine
inside your process you can implement
that using recursion instead of
having to create internal state with
traditional measures
you get coordination possible you can
get back pressure with this which is
quite
useful and difficult to get otherwise
you can dynamically reconfigure these
networks and you can use your
thread pools and your thread resources
efficiently
so i'd just like to thank the guys that
helped me work on it and particularly
timothy baldridge
did the go macro inversion of control
stuff it's really cool and when he talks
about it
at some conference in the future make
sure you catch it so this is where you
can get the code and try it out
uh it's on github this docs there
there's now a maven
artifact for it and there's a blog post
that describes it more
but that's it thanks